We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. My friend Noel works in advertising. That is Starly Kind. And this is her friend Noel.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决食品、能源、健康、教育和环境领域全球最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内开展合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学为提升所有生物生活质量这一使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我的朋友诺埃尔从事广告业。那是斯塔利·凯恩，而这位是她的朋友诺埃尔。
My name is Noel Ritter. And I'm an Associate Creative Director. What is a Associate Creative Director do? Uh, boy. Um, an associate creative director, Guides, uh, helps. Help, oh my god. I don't know what I do. In 2003, Nol was working at an agency in Richmond, Virginia.
我叫诺埃尔·里特。我是一名副创意总监。副创意总监是做什么的？呃，天哪。嗯，副创意总监，指导，呃，帮助。帮助，天哪。我不知道我做什么。2003年，诺埃尔在弗吉尼亚州里士满的一家广告公司工作。
Everyone wanted to work on flashy spots like Apple or Nike or Gatorade. Do you know what wasn't flashy? Insurance. Which is why when a company called Geico became a client, everyone hoped the campaign would end up on their desk. People would run the other way when the creative director for Geico
每个人都想做像苹果、耐克或佳得乐那样引人注目的广告。你知道什么不引人注目吗？保险。这就是为什么当一家叫Geico的公司成为客户时，每个人都希望这个广告活动能落到自己手里。当Geico的创意总监走过来时，人们会绕道而行。
would come down the way. Literally? Yeah, definitely some ducking was happening. Noles and Cherfew is at a wrong water cooler at the wrong time or what, but he ultimately got stuck with Geico. His job is to help them somehow figure out a clever, not painfully boring way
真的吗？是的，确实有人在躲避。诺埃尔在错误的时间出现在错误的饮水机旁，或者别的什么原因，但他最终还是被分配到了Geico。他的工作是帮助他们想出一个聪明、不那么枯燥的方法，
to explain how simple it was for people to sign up for their insurance online. So put this in the context for us because I've seen about a million of these ads at this point. It's true. I feel like these ads are on all the time. Do you watch the Bravo channel at all? No, not at all. If you did, I feel like your kind of top chef is still good. And if you watch Bravo every single commercial for Bravo is an insurance ad.
来解释人们在网上注册他们的保险是多么简单。那么请为我们介绍一下背景，因为到目前为止我已经看过大约一百万个这样的广告了。确实。我觉得这些广告一直在播放。你看Bravo频道吗？不，完全不看。如果你看了，我觉得你喜欢的《顶级大厨》还是不错的。如果你看Bravo，Bravo的每一个广告都是保险广告。
And it's not just Geico anymore because now it's all these TV people selling you insurance, right? There's a president from 24. He's selling you insurance. And there's that loser boyfriend guy from 30 Rock who sells it to you. Well, the maim wants it. I love those. You like the maim? Really? Absolutely. The kids make me skip back and watch them again. But see, there's enough on now that your kid can actually have a favorite. Like back then, like before Geico, there weren't any on, so nobody could even, you wouldn't, nobody would be competing about which was their favorite insurance commercial because there weren't on insurance commercials. And I guess when Geico first came to Noel's office, insurance was almost entirely marketed
而且现在不仅仅是Geico了，因为现在全是这些电视明星在向你推销保险，对吧？有《24小时》里的总统。他在向你推销保险。还有《我为喜剧狂》里那个失败的男朋友也在向你推销。嗯，那个原始人很受欢迎。我喜欢那些。你喜欢那个原始人？真的吗？当然。孩子们让我倒回去再看一遍。但你看，现在播得够多了，你的孩子甚至可以有最喜欢的广告。就像以前，在Geico之前，根本没有保险广告，所以没人会去争论哪个是他们最喜欢的保险广告，因为根本就没有保险广告。我想当Geico第一次来到诺埃尔的办公室时，保险几乎完全是通过直邮进行营销的。
through direct mail. The title is also in the midst of reading the short story collection Pasterelia by the writer George Saunders. The title is about a theme park, which has come to learn how other civilizations live. Among the attractions are Russian peasant farm, pioneer encampment, and wise mountain hermit. The focus of the story, though, is on the prehistoric exhibit, where two actors, a woman and a man, play the part of cave husband and cave wife. No-one loved the way it contrasted two very different elements that shouldn't have gone together. It was like taking a natural cave with stalactites and stalagmites, and then showing what life was like back in caveman times
标题也正处于阅读作家乔治·桑德斯短篇小说集《帕斯泰利亚》的过程中。标题是关于一个主题公园，人们在那里学习其他文明是如何生活的。景点包括俄罗斯农民农场、先驱营地和睿智的山中隐士。然而，故事的焦点在于史前展览，两名演员，一男一女，扮演洞穴丈夫和洞穴妻子的角色。诺埃尔喜欢它对比两个本不该放在一起的截然不同的元素的方式。这就像是找一个有钟乳石和石笋的天然洞穴，然后展示原始人时代的生活是什么样的，
by hiring these low-ren actors. I have to admit I'm not feeling my best. Not that I'm doing so bad. Not that I really have anything to complain about. Not that I would actually verbally complain if I did have something to complain about, no. The story is both very funny and very sad. The caveman husband takes his work super seriously, using body language to communicate.
通过雇佣这些低薪演员。我不得不承认我感觉不太好。并不是说我做得有多差。并不是说我真的有什么可抱怨的。并不是说如果我真的有什么可抱怨的，我就会口头抱怨，不。这个故事既非常有趣又非常悲伤。洞穴丈夫非常认真地对待他的工作，用肢体语言进行交流。
Hardly breaking character, even though weeks pass when no visitors come by to watch. I'm sitting back in my haunches, waiting for people to poke in their heads. Although it's been 13 days since anyone poked in their head. The cavewoman on the other hand speaks English all the time. And Janet speaking English to be more and more. She drinks on the job and tries to get him to loosen up. Which is partly why I feel so, you know, crummy. It's a tedious routine, full of pointless tasks,
几乎不脱离角色，即使几周都没有游客来看。我蹲在脚后跟上，等着人们探头进来。虽然已经13天没有人探头进来了。另一方面，洞穴妻子一直说英语。珍妮特说英语说得越来越多。她在工作中喝酒，并试图让他放松。这也是我感到如此糟糕的部分原因。这是一个乏味的例行公事，充满了毫无意义的任务，
and a lot of the language echoes that of office life. Janet scratches under her armpit and makes it sound like a monkey. Ben lights a cigarette. What a bunch of s*** that she says. Why you insist I'll never know. Who's here? Do you see anyone here but us? At the end of each day, they have to fill out
而且很多语言都呼应了办公室生活。珍妮特在腋下抓挠，发出像猴子一样的声音。本点燃了一支烟。她说，真是胡扯。为什么你坚持要这样，我永远也不会知道。谁在这儿？除了我们，你看到别人了吗？每天结束时，他们必须填写
daily partner evaluation forms. And the cave husband always says his cave wife is doing a good job, even when she's clearly not. I gesture to her to put out the cigarette and make the fire. She gestures to me to kiss her butt. Nol had to hit a wall on the Geico campaign. He and his creative team, whatever that is, are trying to come up with interesting analogies. Maybe they could show a baby who couldn't be potty trained, but who could push the few
每日合作伙伴评估表。洞穴丈夫总是说他的洞穴妻子做得很好，即使她显然没有。我示意她熄灭香烟并生火。她示意我亲她的屁股。诺埃尔在Geico的广告活动上遇到了瓶颈。他和他的创意团队，不管那是什么，都在试图想出有趣的类比。也许他们可以展示一个无法进行如厕训练的婴儿，但他却能按下几个
buttons necessary to file a claim with Geico? Or puppets who kept pulling fire alarms? None of their ideas felt right or special enough. We needed a break and we had gone to lunch and were sitting there eating our lunches, and then all of a sudden I'm like, wait a second, these cavemen from the Saunders' Book like that, that's perfect. And the whole slogan came to me fully formed. It's so easy a caveman can do it. Which of course became the ads that you are probably picturing in your head right now.
必要的按钮来向Geico提出索赔？或者一直拉火警警报的木偶？他们的想法都不够合适或不够特别。我们需要休息一下，我们去吃了午饭，坐在那里吃午饭，然后突然我心想，等一下，桑德斯书里的这些洞穴人，那太完美了。整个口号就这样完整地出现在我脑海里。这太简单了，连原始人都能做到。这当然就成了你现在脑海中可能浮现的那些广告。
Like the George Saunders' story, the ads are funny, but also a little sad. It's our casted cavemen who seemed truly pained by the label that society has given them. Why does that bother you? Why does it bother me? So easy a caveman can do it. Well, it's just a commercial. OK. Well, what if it said, geico.com, so easy a therapist can do it?
就像乔治·桑德斯的故事一样，这些广告很有趣，但也有一点悲伤。是我们选角的洞穴人，他们似乎真的对社会给他们贴上的标签感到痛苦。为什么那让你困扰？为什么它困扰我？这太简单了，连原始人都能做到。嗯，这只是个广告。好吧。那么如果它说，geico.com，这太简单了，连治疗师都能做到呢？
Well, then commercial wouldn't make sense to me. Why not? Well, therapists are what? Smart. Noel says when the caveman commercials first aired, his agency received several letters from individual viewers, asking of a blurry caveman playing a piano in the background to one of the spots was the actor Bell Kilmer.
嗯，那广告对我来说就没意义了。为什么不呢？嗯，治疗师是，什么？聪明的。诺埃尔说，当洞穴人广告首次播出时，他的公司收到了几封来自观众的信，询问在其中一个广告背景中弹钢琴的模糊洞穴人是不是演员贝尔·基尔默。
The commercial put Geico on the map. So that got Starly wondering if she could trace the trail of inspiration back even further. So she called up George Saunders to ask him about some of the influences in his life that made him the kind of writer he is. Normally when you're a writer and you go on tour and people talk a lot of inspiration,
这则广告让Geico声名鹊起。这让斯塔利想知道她是否能追溯到更早的灵感来源。于是她打电话给乔治·桑德斯，询问他生活中让他成为那种作家的影响因素。通常当你是一名作家，去巡回演讲，人们谈论很多灵感时，
you have a kind of a bull-****-list. Yes. A little Shakespeare, you know, a told story. And then if you think deeper, there's a other list which is actually sometimes a little bit embarrassing, even you know, a total story. And if you think deeper, there's other lists, which is actually sometimes a little bit embarrassing, even you know, or at least it is coming from a different direction. And by different direction, what he's trying to say is
你有一个所谓的“胡扯清单”。是的。一点莎士比亚，你知道，一个托尔斯泰的故事。然后如果你深入思考，还有另一个清单，实际上有时有点令人尴尬，甚至你知道，或者至少它是来自不同的方向。而通过不同的方向，他想说的是
that Charlie Brown, peanuts, Christmas, and Halloween, shells are embarrassingly big in my childhood. I'd never seen anything that was quite so tonally complicated or something, but I felt a real direct line between the way I was feeling about things and the way my neighborhood looked and felt. For example, I would do a lot of dreamy walking around the neighborhood and really love that you see him in line as doing that.
查理·布朗、《花生漫画》、圣诞节和万圣节，这些在我童年时期大得令人尴尬。我从未见过如此基调复杂的东西，但我感觉到我对自己感受到的事物与我邻里的外观和感觉之间有一条直接的联系。例如，我会经常在邻里间做梦般地走来走去，真的很喜欢你在《花生漫画》中看到他那样做。
And it seemed that just reassure you somehow that your experience is actually really sacred. You know, it's really valuable. Your neighborhood is really as important as any other place in the world. You know, part of the thing of influence is that we think there's something in the world that intrudes on us and changes us. But the other way to see it is there's something in us that finds a mirror. And then I think when you go to do some work, something and you rise us to it. George was also influenced early on by the jerk, money python and jaws.
这似乎以某种方式让你确信你的经历实际上是非常神圣的。你知道，它真的很有价值。你的邻里确实和世界上任何其他地方一样重要。你知道，影响的一部分是我们认为世界上有什么东西侵入了我们并改变了我们。但另一种看待它的方式是，我们内心有什么东西找到了镜子。然后我认为当你去做一些工作时，某件事，你就会提升到那个高度。乔治早期也受到《阿呆与阿瓜》、蒙提·派森和《大白鲨》的影响。
When you the teenager, he listened to his favorite yes album over and over and over again, fixated on the way they had ordered their songs. Why is that song third? What did you mean? What did they mean by putting this one last? The dat later influenced how you ordered your stories in Detroit called 100%. After high school, George became an engineer. When he first started seriously writing, he read only authors who were dead, Hemingway, Keraq, Maler, he consciously tried to avoid all living writers. And one day, just to get it out of the way, he went to the Chicago Public Library and piled together a stack of literary journals. I sat at the lunch at, my goal was to read about 15 lily-rimagging so I could then totally
当你十几岁时，他一遍又一遍地听他最喜欢的Yes乐队专辑，专注于他们排列歌曲的方式。为什么那首歌排在第三？你是什么意思？他们把这一首放在最后是什么意思？这些后来影响了你在《100%》中排列故事的方式。高中毕业后，乔治成为了一名工程师。当他第一次认真写作时，他只读已经去世的作家的作品，海明威、凯鲁亚克、梅勒，他有意识地试图避开所有在世的作家。有一天，为了完成任务，他去了芝加哥公共图书馆，堆了一叠文学期刊。我坐在午餐桌旁，我的目标是读大约15篇文学作品，这样我就能彻底
abandon the contemporary story, not have to bother with it anymore and go back to trying to be Hemingway. He would open a magazine, start reading a story, and then push it aside, thinking it was dumb. Then he came across a short story called Hot Ice by a Chicago author named Stewart Dieback. It was the first time I'd ever had the experience of reading a work of literature that was set in a physical place in time that I knew. And literally in 15 minutes I l lurched for it and I understood
放弃当代故事，不必再为此烦恼，回到尝试成为海明威的状态。他会打开一本杂志，开始读一个故事，然后把它推到一边，觉得它很蠢。然后他偶然发现了一个叫《热冰》的短篇小说，作者是芝加哥作家斯图尔特·戴贝克。这是我第一次有阅读文学作品的经历，故事设定在我所知道的物理空间和时间里。真的在15分钟内，我被它吸引了，我理解了
the relationship between actual experience and literature in a way I never had before. But I mean, not like your stories are these hyper realistic scenes. No, you're free to invent 100%. You can just make up whatever you want, knowing that your experience will come through you onto the page, even if it's a theme park, even if it's cavemen, because in that story, you know, in the direct story, it's not really a real story at all, but you can feel that the directs hard to sing. Whatever it takes, we're going to get this machine up and flying. We're going to use the streets for all it's going to use mythology. We're going to use poetry, you know, that I don't know what the hell he was doing. It was so crazy. But at the end, I was shaky. And tears in my eyes.
实际经验与文学之间的关系，这是我以前从未有过的。但我的意思是，你的故事并不是这些超现实的场景。不，你可以自由地100%发明。你可以编造任何你想要的，知道你的经历会通过你呈现在页面上，即使它是主题公园，即使它是洞穴人，因为在那个故事里，你知道，在那个直接的故事里，它根本不是一个真实的故事，但你能感觉到那个导演想要表达的东西。无论付出什么代价，我们都要让这台机器飞起来。我们要利用街道，我们要利用神话。我们要利用诗歌，你知道，我不知道他到底在做什么。这太疯狂了。但在最后，我颤抖了。眼里含着泪水。
The face was red. I mean, I mean. And then you did do it immediately to start trying to write like that then? Yep. Yep. Immediately. I like that night.
脸红了。我是说，我是说。然后你立刻就开始尝试那样写作了？是的。是的。立刻。就像那天晚上一样。
Which got me thinking, what influenced Stewart Diebeck to write the way he did? I called him up at the place in Florida. He rents every year, where he catches fresh fish every morning and then fries him up for lunch. Stuart told me that when he first started writing, he had also fallen in love with the great American realists. Saul Bellow and Scott Fitzgerald and Nelson Aldrin.
这让我思考，是什么影响了斯图尔特·戴贝克以那种方式写作？我打电话给他，他在佛罗里达租的地方，他每年都去那里，每天早上捕新鲜的鱼，然后炸了当午餐。斯图尔特告诉我，当他刚开始写作时，他也爱上了伟大的美国现实主义者。索尔·贝娄、斯科特·菲茨杰拉德和纳尔逊·奥尔格伦。
It had never occurred to him to write any other way. He always wrote while listening to music. When he was 25, he became enchanted with two Hungarian composers, Zoltan Kodali and Bella Bertak, who had traveled around Eastern Europe recording music on phonographic cylinders. He went to the Chicago Public Library, the same one that George Saunders would go to years later when he discovered Stuart's story, and checked out as many bar talk and Kodali records as he could find. later when he discovered Stuart's story. And checked out as many bar talk and Cadolay records
他从来没想过用其他方式写作。他总是边听音乐边写作。25岁时，他被两位匈牙利作曲家迷住了，佐尔坦·科达伊和贝拉·巴托克，他们曾周游东欧，用留声机圆筒录制音乐。他去了芝加哥公共图书馆，就是乔治·桑德斯多年后发现斯图尔特故事的那个图书馆，借出了他能找到的所有巴托克和科达伊的唱片。
as he could find. And I put this music on and sat down to write a story about some stuff we used to do as kids and the neighborhood pills of that. I grew up in an inner city neighborhood on the southwest side. And it's kind of corny to say you went into a trance, but I was taken out of myself. And after I turned the music off and looked at the three
我能找到的。我放上这些音乐，坐下来写一个关于我们小时候做过的一些事情以及邻里琐事的故事。我在西南区的一个内城社区长大。说你进入了恍惚状态有点老套，但我确实被带出了自我。在我关掉音乐并看了那三
or four pages that I had written, I realized that I was writing in a way I had never imagined. I could write in a voice I didn't know I had. The music had just opened something up in me. just opened something up in me. Stuart says that listening to that music was a central thing that would happen to him as a writer. Everything he would write from that point on was due to putting those two records on. Barthocking Giddali were influenced by the work of the French composer, Debussy, who was inspired by the work of the poet, Bodelaire, who loved the work of Edgar Allan Poe.
或四页我写的东西后，我意识到我正在以一种我从未想象过的方式写作。我可以用一种我不知道自己拥有的声音写作。音乐刚刚在我内心打开了一些东西。斯图尔特说，听那种音乐是他作为作家发生的核心事情。从那时起他写的一切都归功于放那两张唱片。巴托克和科达伊受到法国作曲家德彪西作品的影响，德彪西受到诗人波德莱尔作品的启发，波德莱尔热爱埃德加·爱伦·坡的作品。
Bodelaire wrote that he loved Poe because he was like him. Quote, the first time I ever opened a book by Poe, I discovered with the rap, Cher, and awe, not only subjects which I dreamt, but whole phrases I'd conceived written by Poe 20 years before. Poe's story, The Raven, was inspired by a bird in Charles Dickens' story, Barnaby Rooge, which Poe would actually pan in a review he wrote when the book first came out. The bird in Dickens' story was inspired by the real-life pet, a Raven named Grip, who died from eating paint chips.
波德莱尔写道，他热爱坡是因为他像他。引用，“我第一次打开坡的书，我带着狂喜、敬畏和惊叹发现，不仅有我梦寐以求的主题，还有坡在20年前写下的我构思过的整句短语。”坡的故事《乌鸦》受到查尔斯·狄更斯故事《巴纳比·拉奇》中一只鸟的启发，坡在书刚出版时写的一篇评论中实际上批评了这本书。狄更斯故事中的鸟受到现实生活中一只宠物的启发，那是一只名叫格里普的乌鸦，它因吃油漆碎片而死。
Which brings us back to the caveman, who surely drew, at least a drop of inspiration from the lovely bird song. Didn't those guy co-cafe minutes inspire a half hour said come? Yes. Did that inspire anyone? No. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Starly Kine with a little help from me Roman Mars. It's a project of KALW, 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, and American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Support for 99% invisible is provided by the Facebook design team who believes that
这把我们带回了洞穴人，他们肯定从那只可爱的鸟儿身上汲取了一点灵感。那些Geico洞穴人没有启发半小时的情景喜剧吗？是的。那启发了任何人吗？没有。《99%隐形》本周由斯塔利·凯恩制作，并得到了我罗曼·马尔斯的微小帮助。它是旧金山当地公共广播电台KALW 91.7和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。《99%隐形》的支持由Facebook设计团队提供，他们相信
design can bring positive change to the world. Visit them at facebook.com slash design. Support is also provided by Tiny Letter at Tiny Letter dot com. Email for people with some binesay. If you can email from my son, Maslow, it would probably be comprised of pages and pages of images of Bruce Banner turning into the Hulk. I love Hulk, but I'm awesome.
设计可以为世界带来积极的改变。请访问 facebook.com/design。Tiny Letter 也提供了支持，网址是 TinyLetter.com。这是为有想法的人准备的电子邮件。如果你能收到我儿子马斯洛的电子邮件，它可能由一页又一页布鲁斯·班纳变成绿巨人的图片组成。我爱绿巨人，但我很棒。
I swear he gets to earth those all day. It's the simplest way to write an email newsletter, tinyletter.com, from the people behind MailChimp. 99% invisible is distributed by PRX the public radio exchange making public radio more public find out more at PRX.org. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. A lot of stuff happens on the Facebook page you should join us there. I tweet at Roman Mars. Oh you know what's brand new? Playlists from Groove Shark and Spotify of songs that I use in 99% of visible episodes.
我发誓他整天都在画这些。这是写电子邮件通讯最简单的方法，tinyletter.com，来自MailChimp背后的人。《99%隐形》由PRX公共广播交易所分发，让公共广播更公开，欲了解更多信息，请访问 PRX.org。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。Facebook页面上发生了很多事情，你应该加入我们。我在推特上叫Roman Mars。哦，你知道什么是全新的吗？来自Groove Shark和Spotify的播放列表，里面有我在《99%隐形》剧集中使用的歌曲。
So you can score your life like it's an episode of 99% Invisible. It's all there and 99% Invisible. Daughter. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以你可以为你的生活配乐，就像它是《99%隐形》的一集一样。一切都在那里，99%隐形。点。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。